Hello everybo... I just realized I forgot to tweet that I'm live.
Give me a sec.
Live now.
That's awkward.
Whoops.
Give me a sec.
I just realized I was like, I did it.
And I was like, oh wait, I didn't do it.
I forgot the most important part.
I'm saying I'm live.
Hello everybody.
I am back.
So why am I back here?
Well, for those who don't know, I forgot to... I was short two hours, two and a half hours.
I said, that's what... wait, let me double check the exact... two hours and 31 minutes.
So I need to stream two hours and 31 minutes and then I'm done.
I'm done for this month and then I do it all over again next month.
But for next month, it'll be a lot easier because...
I don't know.
I don't know if I want to... I feel bad because I am playing high elo games like...
The games are high elo though.
That's the thing.
Like I will be... I am like the deciding factor of whether or not these people will be safe in top 500.
I am literally that person.
And I don't know if I want to... and it's all gonna be live on stream too.
So they have evidence to report me...
actively throwing their games.
If it was off stream, then I could just be like, oh sorry, I was doom queuing.
But then now people know I'm drunk and people know I've been drinking.
So I feel like it's... okay, to be fair, I've had other players throw my games while they're drunk.
But it wasn't top 500.
Okay, I was trying to... no, it was.
I was trying to get top 500 the last two days.
I'm not gonna make it guys.
I'm not getting... I'm not making it this season.
The rank reset really fucked up everything for me.
I do not... I did not have the time committed to grind as much as people did because of the rank reset.
I did not have the time.
But I also procrastinated a lot of my other actual work stuff to try and get it the last couple of weeks.
But like, I just couldn't.
It was just... it was too hard.
It was... I had a lot of really bad games.
I had some... I doom queued at one point.
And then I had some really bad games.
I also got flamed a lot too because of my doom queuing hours.
I was an elo terrorist.
So I don't know if I want an elo terrorist to get... I'm not gonna lie.
I was definitely an elo terrorist when I was doom queuing.
And like, I don't know.
I don't know if I want to... I don't know if like, I can live with the fact that I took away someone... I actually know I can.
I can sleep pretty well.
No, I can... I lie.
I can...
I can sleep pretty well and also like, can live with the fact that I ruined...
I might have ruined someone's chance to get in because if I can't be happy, no one can be happy.
But the... but the only thing that's like... the... okay, all right.
I'll admit it.
The only thing that's actually trying to prevent me from actually queuing up rank on my... because I only have...
I don't want to play low elo games too because that's not fun.
But like, because then like the low elo players are even... are even worse like, in terms of like, toxicity.
But like, because they think they deserve to be higher rank but they're not.
So then they're like, oh, it's because of you guys that I'm not hiring.
Anyway, the only thing that's preventing me from like, wanting to do it is because I'm streaming it and that like, people have like, concrete evidence that I was not sober.
Like...
If it was off stream, then I feel less... I don't... I feel... actually, I don't feel guilty.
I'm just...
I just don't want to get caught.
Like, I... I feel zero guilt.
Like, if it was off stream, I could be like, oh, sorry.
I was just having a bad... I was just having a bad day.
So like, um, I... I was doom queuing.
I'm sorry.
But then like... but now that I have... people have evidence that I was definitely not sober.
I can't delete the VOD!
The whole point of me streaming right now is that I need to get my hours in.
I need to get my last two and a half hours in.
So... so I... I like, fit the quota.
So I get my quota.
Um... um... she... thank you for twitch prime.
Thank you.
Uh... um... Edison, thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Uh... but yeah, thank you guys.
Alphina, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you.
Um... what a quota is... so for those who don't know what the quota is, I have a partnership with Marvel Rivals where, um, trunk rank isn't batable.
Yes, but like, the lobbies I'm gonna get are with other pro players and other high-ranked players.
Guys, they're gonna remember what I did.
If I fucked over someone... um... if I fucked over there... there... I'm gonna get on a list.
Guys, I don't want to get on a list, guys.
Okay?
I... I don't want... I don't want to get on anybody's list, guys.
I... I'm scared.
Guys, they have a list, guys.
It's just like... okay, for those who don't know, back in the Overwatch days, um, the high... the high-ranked Overwatch players actually actively kept an int list... inting list.
So, like, for people they don't like or, like, have, like, done... like, they don't like, they will intentionally sabotage their games, um, because they, like, fucked them over.
Like... or, like, they're, like... like, if they did anything, they put them on the list.
And I don't want to go on that list, guys.
I... I've been a... I've been a...
I've been a... I've been a good VTuber.
I've just... I've been a good boy.
I've been a good boy, guys.
Santa said he's gonna get me presents on Christmas.
I do not want to get the cold... the cold neck this year.
Um, uh, no, I am not overthinking it.
They're... at one point, they're, like, um, I wrote... okay, for those who don't know, old Overwatch drama.
At one point, it... the... the Overwatch int-list got leaked to the public and... and to other streamers.
And, um, it was really bad, because basically, um, people were getting paid to intentionally sabotage games.
Like, this is old Overwatch lore.
So, it's, like, every time you sat... you... you, like, intentionally sabotage a game, um, you get paid X amount of money, and then you just send in screenshots, and then your PayPal...
and, like, they give you, like, gift cards or, like, PayPal transfer shit like that.
So, like, guys, knowing the path Overwatch took, I don't want to be on that list, guys.
Because the one time... because... because the one time I... I decided to drink and not be sober while playing Marvel Rivals ranked, guys.
Guys, I don't have the pro player killout, guys.
I didn't win first place in the MRC.
I don't have that.
All that I am to them is just some fucking anime PNG.
That's all I am to them.
Purple, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
So, yeah, I don't know.
I don't know.
I'll see how I feel later on.
Maybe... but then, like, okay, the thing is... the most fucked up thing is that I do have another...
I do have... I have two eternity counts.
One is my main, which is the high elo lobbies, and the other is low eternity.
But then what if I made someone drop out of eternity?
Oh, but then I won't see them again.
Okay, I might make... oh, man, but then I get caught.
And then maybe I get twitlocked, mate.
Like, streamer doesn't care about other... streamer doesn't take competitive seriously.
Purpose... purposely play so bad that it ruined my chance to be in eternity.
Streamer greased my game, does not take competitive seriously.
What kind of role model is she?
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
I don't know, man.
I'll see how I feel.
I'll do a couple of quick play first to see how I feel.
I'm still sipping on my soju.
I won't finish this soju, not gonna lie.
It's just a game.
I spent 14 plus hours last... on Marvel Rivals each day the last three days, guys.
The amount of things and texts I've read the last three... I don't know how I'm mentally here.
This is why I'm drinking too.
I... The stuff I've seen and the stuff I've heard in the last three days with four 13 plus hours of Marvel Rivals.
I am pretty sure if any of those things got like... because I played a lot off stream too, but like if any of these things got and I was said while streaming, I may or may not have to like delete the vibe.
People were... People... People were not happy during like the end of the season rank ride.
People... Okay, this one was a good quote though, not gonna lie.
Like, I was like, okay, that's pretty clever.
But I was like, also that's like fucked up.
Like, bro, like chill.
Okay, so um, it was this guy in my lobby who was saying some really fucked up shit.
And then like this other guy was like being like, hey, that's not cool, man.
Like stop saying shit like that.
And then like, and then that guy that was saying some fucked up shit was like, um, it's okay.
I'm in the Marvel Rivals category.
This counts because I'm talking about Marvel Rivals.
They told me it still counts in the hours as long as I'm talking about Marvel Rivals.
So this is my loophole before I boot up the game.
I'm, I'm padding the time, guys.
I'm padding the stats right now.
Like, so, um, so basically, um, this other guy was like, hey, that's not cool.
Don't say that.
Like, bro, like, that's like, don't, I don't remember what he said, honestly.
Like, I, like, I heard a lot of stuff.
Guys, you don't understand.
I, I heard a lot of things and I've read a lot of things.
That was going on in the chat.
Um, um, anyway, like, I don't know.
That's why I'm drinking now.
Like after like the post-depression rank grind of not making it.
Um, anyway, so the guy that was like slurring and saying some really fucked up shit, he was like playing Luna Snow, right?
So like, she has the ability to put on a snowflake on somebody and it's like a Zen, a Zen orb, right?
And he was like, where's the snowflake?
Oh, there he is.
Here's a snowflake for a snowflake.
I was like, oh my God.
And like, I was like, okay.
That like stuck in my head.
I was like, holy shit.
No, but he was an asshole though.
Like that, that guy that was like saying something, he said some, he was saying some really fucked up shit.
I was like, like some very out of pocket stuff.
And like, I was like, Jesus Christ.
Like that, like that line, like that quote, like stuck in my head.
Cause I was like, okay, that's, that's pretty clever.
Like that's pretty, you're still an asshole, but that's, that's pretty fucking clever.
Um, next thing, thank you for gifting a sub to Cryer.
Thank you.
Um, um, anyway, no, it's bad.
It's bad.
It's, it's very bad for my health.
I, I, I was not okay.
I'm still not okay.
And then I had a, oh my God.
I'm trying to remember this game.
Um, oh my God.
It was, I had, guys, I had so many games.
I don't.
I had so many games.
I like, they all like blurred together.
Sometimes I don't even remember when I played these games.
I was just like, I don't remember the exact moments when this happened.
Like all these games have just blurred in together.
Cause it just all feels the same now.
I mean, I, I'm, I'm, I was not, no, I, yeah, no, I was in fucking elo hell.
That was, that was a miserable experience.
Um, this rank season has been honestly a very miserable experience if you're trying to get to top 500, but if you're playing for fun, like, and you don't care, it's fine.
But like when I, I try to take rank seriously the last week or so, and oh my God, it's fucking awful.
It's so, it's so bad.
Did you have any, bro, I can't even think of any good memories right now.
Like it has definitely like outweighed the bad.
I, I have like, I cannot like think of a good rank memory the last week, the last week.
I literally can't.
It's all been like a blurry mess.
What's the worst memory?
Um, the worst memory I've had.
Oh man, I told, I said a lot.
Like there were so many people.
Okay.
My, the worst memory is that when I'm playing with a professional player and, or like a player that's like well-known in the higher tier lobbies.
So like who are like, who like peaked like, you know, top 10 or whatever.
Um, and uh, so like, but like they're fucking up.
Like they know they're fucking up.
They've done like fucked up, like fucked plays or like they're intent, they're like inting and stuff and they're inting and stuff.
But like, I get blamed.
Cause they're like, oh, I can't blame the pro player obviously because like, you know, he's well-known in the scene.
And then they would blame me as the support player.
It's just like, what did I do?
I was so confused.
I was like, what did I do?
Like this person literally inted his ass off like four times in a row, but it's my fault.
Like the rat.
And then my friend would be like, no, it was my fault.
I don't understand why nobody said anything about what I just did.
I literally died first, like four times in a row because I decided to ego challenge this person.
And I was like, yeah, why didn't anybody say anything about you?
And then this happened to me multiple times during like the last week.
Cause I was like, what the fuck?
I was like, what did I do?
I literally just tried to fucking survive.
Like, yeah, no, this part counts cause I'm talking about Marvel Rivals.
Um, yeah.
So I was so confused.
I was like questioning, I would be like, what did I do?
I didn't do any bad, but they're like, oh, we lost because of you.
And I was like, what?
Did you not see my thing?
Literally fucking ran straight in and just collapsed from a fucking heart attack three to four times in a row.
Like nothing can save him.
I'm so confused, but that's like, um, that's like, um, one of my bad memories of it.
It's just cause like, it's so weird.
It's so weird.
They're too scared to yell at a, they're too scared to say anything to a pro player or like someone who is known in the like ranking slash streaming scene for just primarily Marvel Rivals.
Like those players are these like random players that are like just rank grinders.
They're too scared to say anything because they're like, oh my God, obviously they're really good players.
So they're just like, let me blame somebody that I don't know that like, you know, somebody that's not really in the scene and stuff like that.
And then I get picked sometimes like, like it's like, and they always pick the support players.
It's so fucking weird.
It's actually, um, it's so weird.
It's actually so fucking weird.
They always pick the support players.
So it's like, I always like, I don't always get targeted, but like if something bad happens and like, and I don't know, I played so many hours.
Uh, I played so many fucking hours that it happens occasionally.
It happens at least like if I do like a 13 plus hour grind session, um, for a day, um, it happens like at least three to four times out of like, I play a lot.
That's, that's a lot of games within 13 hours, by the way.
So it does happen like three to four times.
And I'll be like, who are these people?
Like, this is the very first time I've ever seen you.
Like, who, who are you?
I've never seen you before in this ELO.
Um, but yeah, I thought that was like, uh, super interesting.
Um, I don't, I can't think of a happy memory right now.
I'm like, what can I think of that would make me happy?
I don't know, guys.
I don't know.
Grinding is not happy.
Um, um, no, it's because like, I do enjoy Marvel Rivals.
It's the top 500 rank grind.
That's very, um, when I do it off stream, it's the top 500 rank grind.
That's not great.
It's not fun.
Um, it's not actually fun fun.
Like, you do it just because it's for, you do it for the end result of getting, of getting the rewards from it.
It's like the, it's not the journey.
It's the reward you get at the end.
Um, and that's why I do it.
But this is also my last season of trying, trying harding off stream to try and get it because I wasted so much time trying to get it for this season because I was like, Ooh, shiny badge.
No, I don't even get a paycheck at the, cause I do it off stream.
I do.
That's the worst part.
I could have fucking, I could have streamed 14 hours a day of that session.
I could have done that, but instead I did it all off stream.
So I don't even get paid for it.
And now I'm back here to do it after, after unsuccessfully getting it.
I'm sorry.
I've been drinking guys.
I should be specific that I am most definitely not sober right now.
I should be more specific.
I should like, um, let me fix my title real quick.
Not sober.
Not okay.
Um, okay.
Not so, not sober.
There we go.
There's no drops by the way.
I'm lying on the side.
I'm not gonna remove it.
Um, um, uh, but yeah, so that's why I'm back here after like crawling to my bed in defeat.
I, like rivals decide to like fucking kick the dead puppy that's lying on the floor.
That's a wrap.
I still have to do two and a half.
I don't even get a chance to like, you know, what's it called?
What's that word called?
Like, um, when you're like, uh, processing everything and like, uh, what's that word called when you're trying to process everything that happened and just be like, it's all right.
It's okay.
Decompress.
No, no, not, not disassociate.
I don't know if decompress is the right word, but like, um, oh my God.
Grieve.
No, no, that's not, that's not coping.
I am not coping.
I'm not coping.
Crazy.
Thank you for the 200 bitties.
Thank you.
I guess like process, process, like the defeat and like going through, I haven't even gone through the five stages of grief yet.
I'm just, I, I, drinking is definitely not part of, I'm not at the recovery phase yet.
Like, I'm literally, like, I just got put back into the, the ocean and be like, swim.
I'm like, okay.
Trick, yeah, I'm at stage zero.
I'm still at stage zero.
I haven't like processed anything.
Like, like I'm still in denial stage at the moment.
I am the streamer that, that like is, is going through it right now.
Um, anyway, so like, yeah, that's why I'm here right now.
Um, but like, I will still be streaming Marble Rivals, but I will be doing, streaming my rank grinds now.
I won't be doing, I most likely will not be doing my rank grinds off stream anymore.
If I am, it's basically me.
I can't fucking talk.
It's mostly just talking, not talking.
Oh my God.
Sorry.
I can't word right now.
It's mostly just like hanging out with my friends.
Um, if they want to play, if they want to duo, oh wait, it's only duo queue.
Sorry, I forgot.
Apparently next season is duo, trio queue only.
Oh, sorry, not duo.
Duo, solo queue only when you're eternity.
So most, if I'm like streaming rank off stream, it's mostly, I just want to hang out with some friends and duo queue or some shit.
Um, and like, I don't really want to sometimes like, you know, I want to chill and hang out with people.
Um, but other than that, majority of the rank sessions for Marvel Rivals will now be streamed here.
Uh, well, it's always been streamed here, but majority of them will be like streamed now instead of playing off stream.
And it'll be much more casual.
So like, as in like, if I get eternity slash top 500, I just happen to like, just get it.
It's not like I'm trying for it or any, in any way.
It's just more so I play, I just play the game and I still need to get, I need to get my quota hours still.
So that's all right.
Um, so as long as like, you know, I'm just there for the, uh, just to get the hours in.
Uh, but yeah, that's basically it.
Uh, I'll still be streaming Rivals.
I'll still be playing rank on stream.
Um, I just won't be like, I won't be like, be like, I have to end top 500.
Sorry guys.
I'm won't be streaming for a bit.
Cause I'll be playing Marvel Rivals.
Like that won't be happening anymore.
Um, because like, I have an actual problem.
I, I really do.
I, I'm just incredibly, I'm incredibly addicted to seeing numbers go up.
Like it's like in the competitive setting.
I don't know why it's just for some reason, like, like it's like one of the ways that I like, I like, it's like happiness levels go up.
Like my serotonin levels be like skyrocketed.
I'm like, I must watch my, I must watch my rank points go up.
The only way to make a bird happy.
Well, not the only way, but like in a competitive sense, I'm just an incredibly competitive person.
And it honestly is like, it's just incredibly, it's just addicting.
It's so fucking addicting.
Um, um, Edison, thank you for the 25 gifted subs.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
It's, it's been like that in Splatoon.
It's been like that for Overwatch.
It's been like that for Apex.
And now we're in the Marvel rival stage, um, of like, just trying to have BS, like trying to get top 500.
Cause I like being like, you know, best in the world type deal.
Um, hey guys.
Okay.
That's, I killed like 30 minutes.
Nice.
Okay.
Two hours left.
Nice guys.
Now I just have two hours left.
We did it guys.
It's just that easy.
All right.
Let me pull up.
Let me finally pull up the game.
Marvel Rivals.
Um, I heard there's going to be like, I guess, I don't know when the actual season two patch officially comes out.
Um, but I hate the new map.
Um, wait, actually, it's a new map.
Wait, maybe I can show you guys what the new map looks like.
I hate it.
I hate the new map so much.
It's actually like, wait, okay.
Sorry.
I'll show you guys the new map real quick.
I think, I think the server is still up.
Let me check, double check if I can boot up the test servers for it.
Um, it's not because, it's not just because I hate mutants, guys.
Okay.
My hate is justifiable.
The moment you see Karkoa, or where the fuck they want to call themselves.
Sorry, I'm not sober right now.
Um, but, but like, the map fucking sucks.
It actually, whoa, whoa, she 100% hate.
Guys, guys, it's not, not just that.
Okay.
My hate is justifiable.
My, my hate is incredibly justifiable.
Yeah, mutie scum.
All I'm saying is that, why do they need an island all to themselves?
Why don't you try to integrate into society?
You don't need an island all to yourself.
Okay, let's see, logging in.
I'm gonna check if the servers are still up.
Clearly, they didn't try hard enough.
Okay, all right, this is the test servers.
I'll show you guys.
Okay, so for those who've never if the William, if William Stryker had an alt account, was a VTuber.
All right, I'll show you guys.
Okay, um, custom game.
Okay, create.
I'll just create it just for myself.
Uh, invitation only, no spectating.
Okay, lock room.
All right, come.
Okay, actually, just do invitation only.
Okay, so where is it?
Where's Karkoa?
Karkoa?
Hellfire.
Okay, Karkoa.
Okay, there they are.
Okay, I'll show you guys why I hate this map.
Oh, donations go to Sentinel Protection.
Hey, Sentinels got first place in the official MRC tournament.
So like, am I truly the bad guy here?
Like, why did, why did rivals let them give me first place?
Maybe their ideals are not that... maybe their ideals were true all along.
I'm just saying, if they were truly a bad, if they're truly bad people, how come they won first place in the MRC?
Huh?
And Valorant too, huh?
Does that mean, does that mean Marvel rivals hate, hate mutants?
Huh?
Why would they let them?
Okay, let me show you guys why.
Why?
Oh my gosh, why is the sense?
Uh, keyboard.
That's not my sense.
1.83.
There we go.
And then, where's my melee?
Uh...
Wait, all heroes.
Confirm.
Okay.
And then, there we go.
All right, I'll show you guys.
I'll show you guys.
She's talking.
I'll show you guys why I hate this fucking map.
All right, so like, so okay, where's the point you might ask?
It's over there.
Now, how can you get to point?
Oh, don't worry.
There's multiple ways to get to the point.
If you get lost, you get lost.
But look, there's a passageway right over here.
Whoa!
And then, you get to the point from here.
Or, you can go over here.
And then, you can get to the point from here.
Or, you can run all the way.
You can... Oh my god.
Look at all... Look at how big this map is.
Where's a health pack here too?
Whoa!
Where am I going?
Oh my god.
And then, the point's over...
Oh, is that it?
No, there's a right side too, guys.
Is it?
So like, you gotta... There's so... Oh my... And then, you go down here.
Oh my god.
So like, you go here.
And then, you could go... And down here.
And then, go down here.
And then, you'd be like, what do I do down here?
Oh, good thing you asked.
Boom!
But I could also be like, boom!
Right?
And then, they're like, oh, it's just one portal, right?
Oh, and then, I could jump here.
Oh, you see these portals?
And then, I could go from here to here.
And bro, the high elobies are gonna be so fucking bad.
I hate it.
Not bad, but like, I'll hate it.
And then, when you cap the point, you'd be like, okay, so like... And then, oh, by the way, you can also come down from here and be like... And then, come over here and flank the people on that side.
And... And also, or you can go from here and flank here.
Or you can, you know, or you could go here, and if you're a flyer, you can flank here and be like...
But Doki, it's one portal, right?
No, it's not just one portal.
No, guys, it's not just one portal, because the moment this fucking point hits 50%, we're gonna have more problems here.
We're gonna have so many problems.
Oh, look at that, the portal is opening.
Oh, wow, where is this gonna take me?
So, let me take this portal.
Look where I am.
Wow, where am I, you might ask?
I'm behind them.
And then, you'll be thinking, oh, that's it, right?
Oh, no, no, no, because if I...
If I go back to spawn right now, there is a portal from spawn, and if I take the portal from spawn, I am at the point.
Oh,
you think that's all the portals?
No, no, no.
Also, there's a flanking cave right here for some fucking reason.
There's more on the other side.
There's...
There's more portals on the other side.
Why is there more?
How is there... How is there more?
Alright, I love how this part... Also, I tested it out.
Um, tech... Okay, this is pretty funny, but like...
If you're Ironman, um...
Oh, man, I'll show it to you guys later, but like... Okay, I'll show you.
Okay, so...
Um...
I tested it out, but it's really funny, because you can, like, ult here, and it'll hit an invisible wall.
Because you see, like, oh, it travels really fast, but there's an invisible wall, because the point is, like, literally right here somewhere.
It's, like, right here.
And, like, if there's no invisible wall, I cannot... You could kill somebody from here.
But there's an invisible wall that hit that stops the thing from right here, which sucks, because I thought it'd be really funny.
Okay, hey, you see that portal?
That goes straight to point.
Okay, so you know where the point is?
The point...
is...
right...
Oh my god, it's so fucking stupid.
The point is right here.
It's on the side, because, like, you know why this is so stupid?
Because, like, if you, like, go from spawn, if you start from spawn to there, it's not directly center.
It's, like, it's so weird.
Like, you... this is spawn, right?
You go straight, and then you turn right.
It's so...
It's so weird.
Like, you go here, and then you turn right.
It's not even in this.
Also, I just realized there's a dragon.
Also, this dragon blocks shots, by the way.
Like, like, you can body, like, imagine if you line up... the dragon goes away, by the way.
Imagine if you line up the perfect shot somewhere, like, if you're a mag, and then the dragon fucking flies.
Because you don't know when he comes back.
You don't know when he comes back.
Imagine if you're, like, whoa.
Like, it... like, look, he... look, he blocks it.
When does he come back?
Imagine you're, like, boom, but you have the killing shot.
It's definitely happening.
It's not my problem, because I'm a support, but I get it.
I don't know when he goes away, though.
Like, I already hate him.
Okay, so there's a lot of portals here, too.
There's one over here.
Get out!
Leave!
Okay, so, like, you line up the perfect shot, and then you press Q.
Get your strange portal hit away.
God, I wish.
Where is this area?
Can I fly there?
No, I can't.
Okay, when does he... the thing is, I don't know when he comes back.
Oh, yeah, you just do maximum pulse, and then he shows up.
Like, imagine that.
You have three people lined up right there.
Let's go.
That's 100% gonna happen.
I could feel it.
But here's all the flanking areas.
All right, so I would imagine your perfect 6k gets cockblocked by a fucking dragon that just flies in.
But there's a lot of flanking spots.
Sounds like it.
Like, I'm pretty sure someone's gonna time it, but who the fuck is gonna time the dragon?
It's not just Iron Man.
It's, like, all, like, you know, like, Magneto, all stuff like that.
Oh, yeah, that's my melee.
Like, I'm already lost, but I know I won't get lost when I actually play the game.
But, like, it's so big.
It's such a...
It's such a big map.
Like, I... like, there's so many portals.
There's a portal here.
There's...
There's a portal everywhere.
There's so many.
All right.
All right, so here I'm capping the point.
I'm capping it.
I wish we get, like, the other side.
Okay, we'll wait for 50%.
We'll wait for 50% until... Yeah, like, so there's another... God, I'm stupid.
Get out.
Okay, so there's a portal here, too.
There's, like, there's so many portals.
Like, I don't even remember where all the portals are.
Like, there's too many.
There's another... There's a portal here.
There's one over here.
There's, like, I think at least five portals around that goes to unique places.
Um, there's one over here.
I remember.
Wait, was it here?
Yeah, there's one over here.
There's...
There's one over here.
And...
And there's... There's this one here.
I don't know where this one... Where does this go?
Oh, this one goes to the point.
Okay, so you take this portal.
You go back here.
And then there's, like, high ground.
There's, like, high ground portal right here.
So you take this portal.
You go to the side.
And then...
You gotta remember where... And then, um...
There's... Oh, fuck.
Okay, I don't remember all the portals.
And...
There's too many.
I'm so... I've already lost.
I'm so...
I'm getting fucking lost.
Okay, I've never been so lost in my life.
And then, where's that?
Okay, there's one over here.
There's one that spawned.
The one that from spawned is, like, here.
So you can go here and come back, too.
But when the map needs a mini-map, I just hate the stupid fucking dragon that caught...
I was like, I hate this stupid dragon.
It's like, he just comes in!
What if I have a kill shot right here?!
The perfect timing.
Um...
But yeah, the third one is okay.
I would admit the third map...
The third mini... The third map for this stage is all right.
It's the best out of the three.
Gracoa is on the third map.
It's on the third side.
I have to, like, uh...
Wait, let me see if I can get... I can...
It's a grove.
You can find Gracoa on... in the grove.
Everything.
Oh, at least they're removing some shitty maps.
I'm gonna make Miss Irisa, but, like, I hate the Spider-Man map.
Okay.
I'll... I'll show you guys the...
I'll show you guys the third map.
Or villain, I'm not judging.
Okay.
Um, I think, like, I can... can I get it from here?
Okay, that's central Gracoa.
I need the grove.
All right.
I need them.
I needed to... wait, it's control.
Okay, control Gracoa.
I didn't... it needs to be the grove.
The grove is, like, the actual...
um, the map that... for the third point.
Because it's all random, by the way.
The stages are all random.
I like you guys see this info.
Is this the grove?
Oh shit, it is.
Okay, this is the third one.
Okay, so this is... this is the one where you can talk to Gracoa.
Um, I'm pretty sure, right?
Yeah.
I think... I'm pretty sure the Gracoa is the talking tree, right?
The giant tree with a face.
Um...
No, it's all randomized because it's domination.
So it's all, like, random.
You don't know what you're gonna fucking get.
Okay, that's... I didn't really know who the fucking crow is.
I just, like, saw a giant talking tree and I assumed that's him or her.
All right, so...
This one is the least complicated one out of all of them because it's in the center.
It's... it's actually... and it's, like, more open so you can see where everything is.
So you can see where every... everyone's gonna come.
It's the least complicated one.
The only one I didn't... the only issue I didn't like is the waterfall.
I don't like, like... Okay, so there's a secret portal at the waterfall.
So there's one here.
And then there's, like, one here.
You can be, like...
You can take this... if you take this portal, you'd be over... Okay, so one of my friends said something really interesting.
And what they say is that... Okay, so...
You can play as Namor.
And you... you flank people from here as Namor.
And then you, like... basically, you're, like, throwing your stupid fucking squids up here as Namor because you can see them.
You can sort of... you can throw your stupid ass fucking squids from here.
Like, and then...
Um...
And then if they chase you from here, you could take your stupid ass fucking portal.
And then you'll be...
You'll be here.
And then if they... and then you'll be here and you can leave.
Or you...
You take your... or you lead them here.
You lead the enemy team here to try and kill you.
And then you take this portal.
And you get point.
And then you go... you get down from here.
And then you get point.
So it's like a fucking wild goose chase.
It's...
It's a... it's a fucking...
It's a wild goose.
Yeah, it's some Scooby-Doo shit.
Like, okay, and there's Krikoa right there.
There he is.
Fuck you.
Why did you create this?
CrazyTalon, thank you for the 200 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Fuck you, too.
He is Krikoa.
He's gonna go so hard.
Um, let's see people actually say Krikakoda instead of Krikoa.
Many, uh, thank you for the 500 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
I won't get political.
It's okay.
They're just...
Oh, and then there's another portal.
I am Krikoa.
Um, and I don't care.
This one is not as complicated.
The only... the only complication is...
the fucking waterfall.
And there's like the...
Um, there is the squid.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
There's no more... no meetings here.
No mee... meetings.
No meetings are allowed here.
No meetings.
All right.
So yeah, that's why... this is actually the least complicated map out of all...
Out of all the maps I played for it, this is the least complicated one.
But I hate the portals.
I wish you can destroy them.
Like...
Like, I... I hate.
What about destroyables?
All right, I can destroy the trees.
That's right.
I can destroy it.
That's right, Krikoa.
Fuck your home.
What you gonna do about that?
That's right.
Nothing!
Also, like, um, you can sit on top some of the trees here.
Oh, wait, did I destroy it?
Oh shit.
Okay, that's good.
Oh, you can destroy the waterfall!
Okay, that's actually really good.
I didn't know that.
Okay, you can destroy the waterfall, but you can still hide behind here.
No, people are gonna destroy this area.
Okay, that's nice.
Okay, thank fucking god.
Maximum pulse!
Thank fucking god you could destroy that.
Um, all right, that's good.
That's good.
Okay, because I did not like... the waterfall was the one thing I didn't like the most on this side of the map.
So...
Oh, these are all the breakables.
I feel like when you cap the point...
you can...
um...
You can... you have to break this first, for sure.
I think that's usually... that's most of the breakable stuff.
All right, here's the portal.
Where does it take me?
Where am I?
Oh, back here.
Okay.
Oh, I'm back in spawn.
Whoops.
I took the spawn.
Okay, that portal...
is...
I think that portal.
I'm so lost.
I... which portal did I take?
Which...
Which portal did I take?
I'm so lost.
Oh, the... the dragon leaves his purse for about 22.
Oh, man.
I can't wait to be like what the purse... like have some...
to have... to have someone time.
Imagine being a DPS player and yet the fucking time when the dragon comes back.
Thank you so much for being simpler.
It's a two second cooldown.
Um, so yeah, all right.
That's... that's basically it.
The new map.
I hate it.
That's all I can say.
I'm not a fan.
I'm pretty sure like...
the reason I don't like it a lot is that um, I am pretty sure the moment...
like the higher competitive people figure out this map, it's gonna be so frustrating.
Especially like the flankers.
I... I am not happy as a support player.
Having to deal with more possible flankers.
Like flank options.
I know I'm gonna get absolutely shit on.
By all the like the dive... the dive heroes trying to flank me.
I'm already having a incredibly tough time.
Wait, oh my god.
Okay.
I'll show you... I'll show you a clip of one of the games.
Oh, no, I played so many.
I don't know if I still have the clip.
Oh my god.
Fuck.
I don't know if I still have the history.
I played so many games guys.
It might not even exist anymore.
I'm so sad.
Okay, there was... I had... I was playing against a Spider-Man and Venom.
Um, during the fucked up rank session and it was absolutely a terrible time.
I don't know how like...
I don't know how like how I won that game because it was absolutely... how terrible.
Okay, if I... I'll see.
Let me see if I can find the replay.
I'm gonna open it up right now and see if I can find the replay.
Um, let's see.
I'm gonna see.
Okay, there's a lot of games.
Okay.
A lot of really terrible games.
Let's just... let's just say that there were... there were a lot of incredibly terrible games.
So, I don't know if I still have... I still have... I still have them.
Okay, I know exactly like...
All right.
I know exactly like, um...
Who the people were on the enemy team.
So, I'm gonna check.
I'm checking right now.
Because I was like, you have to watch this terrible fucking time I had.
Okay.
This is this one.
Okay, I know the...
Yeah, I know it was the, uh...
It's not this one.
Okay, you guys can't see it because... all right, I'll show you this.
Okay.
This was when I sort of gave up right here.
This was the moment where I gave up.
It got better though.
It got better.
It got...
But...
It got better.
It took a lot for it to get better.
It took... let's just say that.
It took a while for it to get better.
But... but it got better.
It got... it got better.
I feel... I don't know if I feel better, but it did get better.
It did get better.
Okay, I think it's this.
Is it this one?
Uh...
Let me double check.
I know what... I know like the exact stage it is.
Oh my god.
I wish...
I wish I kept it.
I...
Fuck!
I wish... I wish I have...
the record of it.
Okay.
As long... if they're on Spider-Man, then I'm not showing it because I want to see if they're...
I want to see if I could find...
Oh, no!
Okay, we don't have... guys, I'm so sad, guys.
We don't... okay, but I can show you this though.
I'll show you this.
This is... this part was so fucked up for me.
This...
I'll show you this part.
I...
Okay, this is... okay, so this is me, right?
Okay, watch this, guys.
I don't have this Spider-Man Venom clip any... I don't have the Spider-Man Venom replay because I didn't think that... I wasn't thinking.
Okay, this is... this is me, right?
All right, so...
I'm ready though.
I'm ready.
All right, so watch... I won this game, by the way.
And then I was like, okay, I hear somebody behind me.
Okay.
And then I was like, okay, if anything happens to me, my Loki will copy me.
Yeah?
All right, here I am, son.
All right, I was like, okay.
And then I got whaled.
Okay, that's cool.
And then I got grabbed.
Okay, and then I...
And then I lived.
I...
Okay, I'll show it to you.
I'll show you guys the entire stage again.
Okay, it's right here.
All right, so I was like, all right, nice.
Clobbered.
There you go.
He punches directly at me.
I got whaled specifically.
Okay.
The Wolverine grabs me.
All right, and then I got frozen.
And then he tries to ult me.
And then missed.
He actually...
Tried to ult me after, but thank fucking god.
That he missed.
Somehow you found out and lived.
Straight up hate and shit.
But that...
That was like one of my experiences.
This is one of my rank experiences.
And then my Loki was like, holy fuck.
How did you live?
Our Loki even was like, NPC was like, wow, they really fucking hate you.
The tank experience, but to a strategist.
But yeah, that was...
Um...
That was like...
That was one of my experiences, guys.
You're a trooper.
I survived though.
I... I fucking lived somehow.
But yeah.
Um, unluckily...
Unlucky that I don't have the record.
Of... Oh man, I wish I do, guys.
I actually... I really wish that I save the...
Record for... Because like, you can't go back.
Um, of the Spider-Man...
The Spider-Man map.
Because like, that shit was fucking crazy.
Like...
I was basically...
Booped up everywhere.
Like, I could not live at all.
I'm so sad.
Wait, also, I'll be right back.
I need to refill.
I'm gonna refill my water real quick, but I'll be right back, guys.
I'm gonna refill my water.
Okay, so I...
I... I'm ready to actually play the game.
All right, let's do some quick play and then I'll see how I feel.
I'll see if I feel like, you know, terrorizing or not.
I'll see if... I'll see how I feel, chat.
We'll warm up with some quick play real fast, and then we'll see.
So give me a sec.
Let me...
All right.
Oh, hey, hello, T'Challa.
T'Challa.
I'm warming up with quick play.
I always warm up with quick play, guys.
Before anything.
Okay, nice.
All right.
I wish... I do wish that...
I... I... I wish I saved the VOD of that Spider-Man game.
Um, I finished my Soju!
Flora, thank you for the Twitch Prime!
Thank you, thank you!
Um, but yeah, it's done.
I'm just gonna play cas... I'm gonna play ranked casually on stream.
Like, most of my ranked session for... most of my ranked session for next season, season two, will be on stream.
Um, I'll not... I won't be playing much off stream.
Um, just because I need to get my quotas anyway.
Also, like, I experimented with... I experimented with, like, uh...
Raw input?
I don't like it.
I don't like raw... raw input.
It's way too fucking slow for me, and I'm so used to, like... I'm so used to my...
um, sense that, like, it messed me up so much.
I personally don't like raw input, but I know, like, pro players love it.
Just because, like, it's just more...
like, to them, it's more accurate.
But, like, I'm not pro, so, like, I don't care.
I don't like it because it's way too slow, and I don't want to experiment.
I don't want to experiment with sense... with my sense to find it.
All right.
Maybe it's the last barrier that's holding me back.
I don't know, but it's not for me.
I found out that it just wasn't for me.
I don't know how to play Starlock on this map, honestly, but it's quick play, so it doesn't matter.
I think, like, defense is, like, the worst for this map.
Where are they going?
Oh, are they... are they here?
Oh, they're here.
Hello.
Oh, shit!
Didn't even have to look at him.
I didn't even look at him.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's not fair.
Wait, wait.
Please, please, look!
Oh my god!
Okay.
If you don't look at me, I was walking in a straight line.
Oh, I see you, B!
You have a DC?
Yeah, I'm... I think he just doesn't want to play with this comp.
He didn't want to play support.
That's crazy.
It's okay.
I'm warming up, guys.
I'm warming up.
Our Loki's dead, but I'm warming up, guys.
Jesus Christ.
Like, what?
Wait, they get two supports?
Wait, that's unfair.
Wait, they have...
Oh!
Wait, that's not... Wait, they get three supports in my quick play lobby?!
Like, that's...
That's so messed up.
Why do they get three supports?
Wait, that's illegal.
I didn't go to quick play for people to have three fucking supports.
Wait.
They don't have a tank, though.
We have two tanks with one...
We have two tanks with zero supports, and then they have three DPS.
They have a support per DPS.
Like, they actually...
They actually have a support per DPS.
Like, what the fuck is that?
Wait, that's illegal.
They each have their own fucking pocket.
Like, that's actually illegal.
Like, what am I supposed to do in that scenario?
Like, I'm...
I'm literally just...
Oh my god, hello.
Hello, Ramone.
Hello.
Okay, guys, maybe I should play Rink.
It'll be fine.
Oh, yeah, if you solo... Okay, never mind.
Okay, he's better than me.
Wait, what killed me?
What?
I did not see.
Okay, maybe I'm too drunk right now.
I'm not.
Oh, guys, I don't think I'm okay.
Oh my god, we have two supports!
Oh my... Okay, I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
Do I think there should be a roll cube?
I don't think so.
Oh my god, why do I only fight you?
Why do I only fight you?
Let me fucking see.
Let me see.
I swear to god, I have not seen the other DPS at all.
I have not seen any other DPS except for this fucking...
Oh my god, literally the first person I see...
is him.
There you go.
See, look at that.
If I...
Look at that.
I get to actually experience a different DPS player.
And then I actually killed him.
Okay, I'm like... I'm literally living off of health packs and I'm living off of health packs and like...
just running around like a...
like a headless chicken.
Oh my god, bro, Nitro's just...
Bro, actually, fuck off, bro.
Like, it's not fair.
It's actually not fair.
I want to...
I want to talk to the other...
I want to talk... Oh shit.
Where's my support?
Like, where's my...
Like, bro, we have one tank that's literally AF.
Guys, this is...
Alright, I'll play one more quick play and then I'll terrorize Rink.
I can't.
I ain't.
I can't deal with this.
Bro, let me fucking see somebody else, bro.
Like, I don't care about you, bro.
I actually do not...
Okay, that's fine.
That's actually fine.
You're such a fucker.
You don't have ice.
I know you don't have...
You're such a fucker.
You're the one that's... that's fucking right.
There you go, I knew he was gonna die.
Alright, there you go.
Stop pocketing this fucker.
There we go, he's dead.
The evil is dead.
I needed to kill that one Iceman.
I need to kill Luna Snow to feel anything.
What if I...
That's right, I'm gonna crash your party.
Evil.
Bro, that was... wow, they were trying to have a...
Oh my god, they were just trying to have a pro Loki.
Why can't you heal me like one time, Loki?
I don't under... bro, just heal me once.
I sat in front of you.
I actually sat in front of our Loki.
Holy shit, it's actually crazy.
Wait, this guy is actually purposely trying to kill me.
Wait, that's fucking rude.
Okay, if he's actually gonna try and...
Uh, I don't know.
I don't know what camp... I don't remember.
I think it's Namor.
I actually don't know how to use Namor, so I don't play Namor.
What the fuck?
Where's my turret?
Wait, where did... where did my healer go?
All right, so that was a quick play game.
You are not sorry.
This guy actually only went for me.
There was an entire fucking team and he wouldn't let me like, experience like... I actually have to like, play other characters.
I have to play other characters to fucking run around.
He is not sorry.
I know he is not fucking sorry.
Legit, he ran past... he ran past like, several people just to kill me.
Like, what the fuck?
Now I definitely... I'm terrorized.
I'm playing Hella.
I feel extra terrorizing now.
That's crazy, I never had a quick play.
That was so fucking weird.
That was such a weird quick play.
My team was so fucking weird.
It was my team.
Why was it my team?
No, it's not enabled.
My title is a lie.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I should... I just got lazy.
I forgot to remove it.
No drops.
I just forgot to change it.
I didn't realize the drops were over.
I forgot to change it.
I just forgot.
It's basically it.
There you go.
Now it's true.
There's no drops.
I feel extra just... I don't know if I'll hit anything because my aim is not there today.
I crashed out a lot the last few days.
So like I don't think my aim is here anymore.
No drops, check.
Yeah, I think it's tomorrow.
I don't know.
I don't know if it starts at midnight or if it starts tomorrow or seven hours.
Yeah.
I just don't... I'm gonna see how my aim is like.
Just have an hour to kill.
Okay, where am I?
Okay, I...
Sorry, I like legitimately forgot what my movesets were.
I had to look down.
I'm actually like not okay right now.
I legitimately forgot what I can do.
I'm so confused.
There's a cooldown and I know there's a cooldown.
Wait, where's my other...
Jesus Christ.
There you go.
I saved you.
I'm a hero.
Oh my god, my aim is not okay right now.
I actually am not okay right now.
There you go.
All right.
At least I'm hitting shots guys.
Look at that.
Oh dink, dink, dink.
I have to flank.
There you go.
I'm gonna go flank.
Nice.
My thing hit him.
Get out of here.
Oh my...
No, he's one.
Oh, I got him.
There we go.
Ah, I missed.
No!
Not the way for my cooldown.
Oh no.
The fuck?
Oh, what the... Get out of here.
Get out.
Yeah, leave.
Okay, now I can... No!
Sorry.
I'm not okay.
Why am I saying sorry?
I don't know who I'm saying sorry to, but like I'm actually not okay right now.
All right, I'm not okay at the moment.
Wait, what?
Oh my god, who fucking burned me that fast?
That's actually crazy.
I got burned so fucking fast.
I was not paying attention.
Oh wait, he's one.
Nice.
Okay.
Goodbye.
I love point-and-click adventure.
It's so easy.
I love when it's a point-and-click adventure, guys.
I just have to...
Wait, okay.
I don't know what the flank area is for this.
I don't play Hella as much.
I don't play DPS as much.
It sounds stupid.
Holy fuck, how are you a real person?
Oh shit, goodbye.
It's fine, my team won.
Oh my god.
Okay, I tripped for a shift earlier.
I was just messing about.
How am I the most killed?
I am not paying attention.
Bro, I'm not even alive right now.
Not a person.
I'm not a person.
We need more.
Guys, I have another soju bottle, but like, I don't know if I want to drink one more bottle.
This is drunk aim.
I drank an entire bottle of soju.
I have like one more bottle.
And it's like...
It's literally, it's soju.
It's 12% alcohol and I drank an entire bottle.
Wait, someone's 0-0?
Holy fuck.
I think it was somebody left.
Somebody definitely left.
I would not be- no, this is literally drunk aim.
I'm messing up my buttons right now.
I had to look down because I was like, what buttons do I have?
I forgot like my fucking moveset.
Alright.
I need a flank, I think.
Everything is like an I think right now because I don't remember how to actually properly play these characters.
On the top of my head.
I have to get high ground, I'm pretty sure.
I've seen how they play.
This is how they play frame against me.
Okay, guys.
Woo!
Hey, guys.
Oh, hey.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna die to this.
Watch this.
Okay.
Okay, um, is he still there?
No, my death.
I wanted to die.
Why did he deny me?
Why did he deny me of what I wanted?
Bro, bro, what is your awareness, actually?
What is your awareness?
Holy fuck.
Oh my, that is absolutely embarrassing.
That is so embarrassing.
Alright, you're gonna get out of this and then...
Oh, wait.
Oh, there you go.
I was like, nice.
I still got this.
I'm just saying.
Okay, she's coming over.
Yeah.
Oh shit, hey.
Do I even have to move?
I feel like I don't even have to AD.
I can just stand still.
I mean, it is really mean to play Hella on quick play, but like...
I don't care.
Like, I absolutely don't care right now.
I landed on a squirrel.
It's about... exactly, it's about having fun.
Guys, playing Hella in quick play is actually so fucked up.
Because she's like one of the... she's literally... if you can aim, you can play Hella.
It's like...
It's like not... IMO, it's not that difficult.
If you know how to shoot your gun.
Really?
Up there?
Oh shit.
Oh my god, where's my... hello.
Thank you.
Okay, I have my ult, but like... oh shit!
No, he dashed away!
He dashed away!
It was one hit!
No, they're real people.
Don't worry.
No, that... a real person would make... would ult like that.
I just didn't have my own ult.
If I had my ult, I... it would... I could have killed him.
It would've been... oh my god, that was such a juicy ult play too, if I had it.
If I had my ult there.
That would've been so fucking fun to just threw my shit on it.
Wait, what the fuck?
What are you doing there?
Like...
Hello?
Thank you.
Wait, you got healed?
That's illegal.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Hello.
You can kill him.
It's just...
You can kill this guy.
Bro, if you don't kill him, I swear to god, where is he?
Where... is he just running away?
What is this Looney Tunes shit?
What is this?
He's just running away.
This is bullying.
Hella... yeah, hella is just easy mode.
And see, you just freaking throw shit down.
Hella.
Check.
Oh, yeah, I can check it.
There's no way.
See, they're real people.
Boom.
Like, I programmed a bot to get into my game just to glaze me.
I bought a bot to fucking Q into my game.
I need one more quick play.
And then I'll do... okay, how about I do one ranked game?
I'll do...
I'll terrorize one ranked game.
I don't know.
Wait, actually, how much... how much more do I have?
Oh my god, I still have an hour.
Okay, I still... guys, I still have an hour.
I still have an hour.
Okay.
All right, maybe two.
Maybe two ranked games.
Oh my god, people are gonna be so mad at me.
I don't...
Okay, one.
Oh, no, I don't want to open.
I don't want to open.
Swap accounts.
Guys, I don't feel like swapping accounts.
I am not playing support.
If I'm gonna be in support gel...
What rank is it?
It's eternity.
It's high eternity.
Well...
Low... like, bottom high.
Low... bottom high eternity.
Let's just say that.
It's...
It's bottom high eternity.
It's... it was high eternity.
And...
It was.
Then I got incredibly unlucky.
Now it's the bottom of the high eternity.
No, I'm playing... it's quick play right now.
I'm warming up, technically.
I'm just gauging how... what my aim is like right now.
I'm gauging my aim.
Right now to see how fucked up I am.
And the best way to see how fucked up I am is playing quick play on DPS.
Playing Hella.
This guy almost died.
That's crazy.
All right, how do you flank?
It's here, right?
Usually the Hella players would be right here.
No, right?
Is it?
No, it's on the back side.
They would go to the backs.
I'm pretty sure.
No, they'll go here.
I don't remember, guys.
It's fine.
Oh, they blocked him.
What?
They blocked him.
They body...
They walled him.
How am I supposed to shoot my... my... what am I... what is it?
Dag... mini daggers?
How do I shoot my mini daggers?
Mini daggers if they just block them.
What am I supposed to do?
That's my entire job.
I just go pew pew.
All right, have we not won this fight yet?
You guys killed like four people.
Don't worry, I'm here now.
I won't be doing much, but I'm here now.
I killed him.
I won't be doing much, but at least I'm here.
Where are they?
Oh.
What?
Oh, I didn't see him.
Oh, oh my god, he blends in.
The map is white.
Okay, that's a good shot.
That's actually a really good shot.
But like, I was like, what?
He actually blended in with the map.
That's so smart.
Oh, that's so smart because you can change your skin in the character select, right?
So that you can actually like just... I realized you can actually just like change...
Okay, this widow is actually really good.
All right, let me think.
What counters widow?
This widow is actually really good, so I'm thinking.
Also, it might be because I'm drunk as well.
Maybe I'm not sober, so like I can't see things correctly.
Whoa, hey, can I... can I have like one poke?
Yeah.
That's crazy!
Holy shit!
Did my Loki actually ignore me?
Wait, that's insane.
My Loki actually ignored me.
Okay.
Oh, I'm leaving that.
That ult is actually pretty decent.
Okay, I might have to swap characters.
No, I forgot to break the window!
Oh, that was a good shot from me.
Oh, that's not fair!
Stop getting healed!
What the fuck?
Oh no.
Oh, fuck!
He damage boosted.
Not damage boosted, he like hit me in the middle.
All right, that's fine.
Wait, can I ult you all with this?
No, it's fine.
We win this.
I don't need to ult this.
Okay, I'll ult this.
Hahaha!
Okay, I'm gonna chase... whoa!
He burned me so fast!
All right, I'll swap.
He actually...
He actually burned me so fucking fast.
All right.
I forgot what counter is Widow.
I don't have to deal with it.
I don't have to actually deal with the Widow.
I just position myself in a way where other people deal with the Widow for me.
So I don't remember what counter is in.
Okay, I don't think they see me here, right?
What the fuck?
Okay, this is not good for me.
This is not good.
How did he know?
How did he... I was just like... I'm just gonna wait until I might cool down.
I'm actually...
Wait, how did he know?
I was just chilling.
America!
Yippee!
All right, after this... Yeah, I'll play.
I'll try to play ranked after this.
All right, let's see.
I just wanted to flank.
I just...
All right.
Oh, wait.
Oh my god, they're all like looking for me.
I don't like that.
How am I supposed to flank if they're all looking for me?
That's better.
Let's see.
I mean, I don't want to sink right now.
I actually... I don't want to sink.
My god.
Okay.
All right.
I have to sink, guys.
I just wanna...
I just wanna chill.
Hello.
What the fuck?
You guys are just like... ignoring me.
It's funny.
They're like...
Bitch.
Shut the fuck up.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Like, actually, what is wrong?
Oh my god, they double support ulted for me?
Oh my god, you guys are so cringe.
Bro.
What is... They act... I feel like... I don't know, guys.
That's actually crazy.
That they, like, use so much resources to kill me there.
I don't think they saw me.
I'm trying to figure out where that widow is.
There we go.
I don't know where that widow is.
I've just been trying... I was like, my entire mission is to kill the widow.
I don't...
That's the only thing I wanted to do.
She's been running away from me.
She's... All she's done... I've killed everybody.
But the widow.
No, this is quick play.
This is not...
This is not... Quick play has no SPMM.
It's literally, like, a free-for-all.
Like, I've been killing everything but the stupid fucking widow.
Like, every other character I've, like, touched at least once.
Okay.
But they're, like, actually protecting her.
It's crazy.
Like, I... Like, that's so weird.
They've actually, like, all they've done is just pocketed her.
What?
Where am I?
Bro, what happened to me?
I don't know where I am.
Okay, I really need heals.
Okay, thank you.
Okay.
I don't think... This is absolutely not winnable, but it's funny.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I have no cooldowns, by the way.
I think everybody's dead.
What am I praying?
No, 100%.
I'm not okay right now.
I'm just gonna farm on it.
I'm not...
Is the Soju hitting?
Oh, absolutely.
This is, like... I am... I'm not thinking right now.
I'm just shooting because I can.
I'm just shooting my gun because I can shoot my gun.
I'm like...
I'm like... I'm like... Because, like, how do people play this?
How do people play DPS again?
My brain not functioning very well.
All right, one more.
What about one more, guys?
Okay, but what about one more and then I'll terrorize?
And then I'll do this.
Just shooting my shot.
And then I'll terrorize, rank.
Just one... I swear, last one.
Last quick play and then...
And then we'll see how it goes.
We'll see.
We'll see where it takes me.
All right.
I don't wanna play.
I mean, Storm is fucking easy as hell.
I'm just trying to do freaking things that are, like, in training right now.
One way.
All right, yeah.
I mean, it's just an hour, right?
Just one more hour.
It should be fine, right guys?
All right, I don't want to swap accounts, so I'm just gonna... I'm just gonna play on my main.
I don't want to swap accounts, so good luck.
Good luck to my team.
Good luck.
Don't worry.
Things... Everything will be fine.
It's either people are gonna lose top 500 today.
Lose and gain top 500 because of my actions.
Or...
Or people are gonna lose or gain eternity because of my actions.
So it's fine.
It's one or the other.
Okay.
That's just nice.
What the fuck?
Okay, this guy is not real.
This guy is absolutely not real.
Okay, don't worry.
I can literally just...
Oh my... Storm fights are like so fucking stupid.
Like, I hate doing... I hate storm fights.
Like...
Like, the thing is I am...
I am like absolutely nerfed for storm fights because I don't have a descending down button.
I...
For those who don't know...
I have to look down because... I have to look down because...
Look, I have to look down.
Because my... I need healing is my... my left control.
I... I re... because I don't have... I used...
Okay, I have to rebind.
But I know I have to rebind it when Ultron comes out.
I actually... I don't have it because I...
Uh, the reason why I don't have it is because I was like...
Why do I ever play a flying character?
I'm a support player.
Like...
Get rid of this.
Don't matter.
Yo, fuck this thing, Janna.
Okay.
Wait, there was a... Wait, what?
Okay, where was she?
She was below me this entire time.
The fuck you doing over there?
This has been... Is this end of season quick play?
Or is this quick play at 11?
No.
I never had quick play be like this.
This wild before.
Or is this just the drunk effect?
I've been killing so much when I'm sober that I never realized what their people are like when I'm drunk.
And I'm not like trying as hard.
Is that why?
It makes more sense though, not gonna lie.
It definitely makes more sense.
Just fly up.
Like, you can't kill me if I'm like just flying up top.
Yeah, but like...
I've had... My quick play games have always been like decent.
I've never had like such weird ass quick play before.
I've never like... All my quick play games before this have never been so... Like I've had... All my games have been extremely wild.
It's crazy.
Ooh.
All right.
Okay.
Okay, Doki.
You can totally focus.
You don't want... You don't want to lose games for in rank for these people.
Actually, no.
I can't control that.
I can't make promises.
I can't keep.
No, I can't.
I shouldn't be making promises I can't keep.
Fuck this guy.
I'm not gonna kill him, but like... Fuck him.
Oh, I did.
Cool.
Hahahaha.
I'll take it.
Honestly, I'll take it.
I'll take this.
Can we like... Cap?
I was like, it's fine.
Yeah, yeah, fuck that rocket.
Okay, fuck that rocket in particular.
All right, let's see.
Let's see what I want to play.
Back to... I don't know what I want to play.
I always wanted to learn, uh...
Point and click adventure time.
Fuck that... Yeah, exactly.
Fuck that one rocket in particular.
You know what's up.
You know exactly what's up.
I think the support player got tired of playing support.
Where... Who did she up?
I'll lead the guardians now.
Oh, you're scared.
You're so scared.
Was that targeted?
100%.
I'm fine with that, honestly.
That was targeted too.
That was targeted as well.
Okay.
Seeking a target.
Yeah, I just waited for the scarlet to finish flying so I could go pew, pew.
Instant try karma.
100%.
I do not care.
Come on, finish flying.
Finish flying.
Wait, okay.
Wait.
Nice.
Alright, finish flying.
No, the update's not out.
It's in seven hours.
That's right, run.
Run.
Oh, I didn't even realize he was real.
Uh, where did people go?
Here, right?
Yeah.
Let me wait.
I'm patient.
Wait, he's on Spider-Man now.
Wait, he's on the thing.
Wait, they have an actual- Wait, they- Wait, they went like almost 2-2-2 except for the rocket.
Wait, that's silly.
That's so silly.
Wait, he went Namor?
Really?
He went Namor?
They went Namor.
Spider, okay.
That's- That's funny.
That's actually funny.
They actually went Namor-Spider.
He's trying to hook someone over.
Me.
The wrong person.
The wrong person to hook over.
Wait, I don't know about that, buddy.
Oh my god.
No, fuck you in particular.
Oh my god, you're such a nerd.
You're actually such a nerd.
Yeah, but you couldn't- Oh, wait, you saved him.
Fucking nerd.
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, he did- Oh, I thought he was gonna be on the ground.
That's why I threw it on the ground.
Oh, nice, nice, my Widow.
Nice, go Widow, go!
Yeah, I was like, why did you hook me?
We can all fly, except for our Widow.
I mean, try to get the clip, at least.
That's crazy.
Their team's actually real.
The only thing missing is like literally another support.
They actually try to make a real person.
Oh, that was too fast.
Oh my god.
I'm not meant to aim right now.
Oh my god, I would have hit those.
Nice, she hit those for me.
Okay, this is a hate crime.
Why are both the- Wait, why are both the tanks there?
This is a hate crime!
Why are they both here?
Everyone just wants me dead.
Alright, quick play's a little special today.
Like, this is weird.
The LA is real.
Alright, I'm done warming up on quick play, guys.
I'm done.
I'm done with quick play.
Alright.
Alright, let's terrorize.
Let's terrorize rank, guys.
Okay.
I'll do one game.
If it's bad...
Guys.
If it's bad, we won't- We won't do another.
I actually- I'll feel bad.
I'll feel really bad.
Like...
Okay, I won't feel bad.
But I will- I have evidence.
I have evidence that I was not sober for it.
I haven't drank- I finished one bottle a while ago and I haven't drank since.
Are they roleplaying?
They're always roleplaying!
This is my fucking...
Deathmatch practice.
Why are they always roleplaying?
Stop roleplaying.
Fight now.
I require a fight.
No, it won't be that long.
Because everybody is trying to get last minute top 500.
I hope- I assume it's not that long.
Are you roleplaying?
No.
We're here to fight.
Are you a roleplayer?
Yeah.
I kill all non-roleplayers.
Get out of here.
Alright, nice.
Alright, am I terrorizing?
Am I terrorizing?
Oh, fuck.
I should- Oh, man.
Fuck.
I'm gonna get on a list.
Okay.
Top 256?
I don't know.
I feel a little embarrassed if I have that banner.
Alright.
I can't mess up Luna, right?
I just can't play Loki in my state.
That's too- Loki is way too much thinking.
That is too much thinking for me, right?
I can't play Loki in my current state at the moment.
That might be a little too much, guys.
Also, Baka, thank you for the- Gifting a tier 1 sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, they can deal with the bans.
Oh, I could just rocket.
Wait, okay.
If we win this game, I'll play Rocket.
We have a Loki- Oh, wait, we don't have a Loki.
I gotta prepare for next season, guys.
Guys, guys, guys.
We gotta prepare for next- Is no one banning anything?
Okay, Wolverine.
Okay.
It'll be awkward if my name or thing went up.
I forgot we have a group.
I just banned- I forgot I had a group.
Guys, this is bad.
I almost fucked over the ban line.
I didn't even register in my head that we have a group.
Oh my god.
I could have actually fucked over the ban line.
Okay, if we win this...
If we win this...
I'll play Rocket next match.
Cause then it's like I didn't gain or like- I didn't gain or lose any ELO.
If we don't, it's over.
I can give it to the Hela.
Hela should get it.
Oh my god, I'm not okay.
Wait, we have a Spider-Man?
Oh man.
Okay, our Spider-Man gets this.
Okay.
By the way, you know the funniest thing?
Raccoon is banned on my- It's a banned word.
Like, my moderators have to- It's a block term.
So my moderators have to approve every time.
Every time someone says raccoon, my moderators have to approve the message.
The message does not show up unless it's approved.
Oh, that Spider-Man is dead dead.
Whoa, unless...
Wait, he didn't even get the...
Oh, this is not good.
The reload.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Don't worry, I got you.
Can't get you forever, though.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, we both did it.
Shit, that's unlucky.
I got mine first.
That's unlucky.
We both react.
Guys, this is bad.
Guys, it's not looking so good already.
We doubled support health.
I didn't see how many.
Okay, but we still lived.
Guys, that was...
That was not my fault.
That's not my fault.
That's not my fault, guys.
At least he's communicating.
Good.
Thank god someone is communicating for me.
I was not gonna talk.
Okay, I need to heal my team now.
Oh, shit.
What?
Okay, I need to see this.
I got pulled into...
Oh my god.
Oh, that is...
Oh, they're running...
Oh my god.
We banned Adam and yet you're still running triple support?
How desperate.
How desperate are you for ELO right now?
Oh wait, it's end of season.
They're very desperate.
JK.
I forgot what ELO I'm in.
We literally banned Adam to prevent triple support and I forgot how... I almost forgot.
These guys are close.
End of season, baby.
End of season.
I almost forgot right now.
No, triple support against like in rank grinding in this ELO is for like...
For Adam is like the true...
It's for like...
You know...
I need ELO.
Cause it's like super...
I got hit by something.
I'm confused.
My reflexes are not that fast right now so I'm like...
What hit me?
Legitimately like...
Something hit me.
Touched me right now.
I can't tell.
I didn't know again.
I'm gonna let my invis build all...
Oh, you know when they're actually tilted when no one's talking too?
That's like the true special.
Like no one's talking at all.
Everyone is so quiet.
Everyone is actually...
Oh, okay.
There we go.
Oh my god.
People are talking.
I got you buddy.
Okay, but where is Iza?
Alright.
Yeah, I did that.
Yeah.
I might die though.
Oh nice.
Yeah.
Guys, these are top...
Some of these players are top 500 players.
I love that rank is just a lottery of which player you get.
Yeah.
Unknown is like high up there.
100% yeah.
I'm not joking.
I recognize the names of some of these people.
I know one of them is like smurfing right now in my lobby though.
I looked and he was gone.
He disappeared.
Oh my god.
I looked and...
Jesus Christ.
Please.
Oh my god, he lives!
You live!
Also weird, this guy, the weirdo guy is top 500 too.
Oh my god!
Look at them go!
Look at that, it's just that easy guys.
I'm just that good I guess.
Hahaha!
I'll give the...
I'm just gonna give this to him.
Zeno please pick me!
Here we go.
Is there somebody over there?
I am rude.
What was he looking at?
Hahaha!
I'm so confused.
I'm letting my...
Okay, except I need to make sure he doesn't die.
Okay, that's sad.
Okay, we're doing this on purpose though.
I didn't realize.
That was my bad.
I didn't realize he...
I was waiting for it.
I'll be like, that was my bad.
I thought we could just kill all of them.
That was the last fight.
In the mouth.
With the double.
Look, see?
Perfect excuse.
Also, I didn't think she...
Look, it's actually a strategy.
It's a legit strategy.
If you use double support on the last fight.
You can actually kill all of them.
Sorry.
Oh, I shouldn't tell them I'm drunk.
They'll be like...
Also saw you...
I also sort of press tabbed.
And saw you were at 80.
80.
So I didn't think you'd get it.
When the bucky went down.
Okay.
Okay, look, see?
Look.
I had my excuses ready.
I'm not ready.
I'll go with my group.
Actually, I'll go with my mag.
What?
Who's behind?
What the fuck are they doing?
What the fuck?
What killed me?
So confused.
I have two AFK's.
Wait, we win?
We win?
Okay.
I didn't want to tell them that I'm like, not sober.
Because I feel like they're gonna report me.
Or like, they're gonna avoid me.
And I don't want them to avoid me.
Because I don't want...
I don't want...
Like how they're like, I have slurs in my mouth right now.
Like on the tip of my tongue.
He would have slurred at me if I didn't say I'm sorry.
I got slurred.
Not at a lot, but I heard a lot of slurs.
Wait.
Yeah, because I'm just saying.
What?
Same person who Luna also when we said nine times we're by the way.
Grown women by the way.
Oh, look at that.
People are starting...
See?
This is more fun when like, you're not sober.
This is 100% more fun when you're...
But like...
Like...
I told you guys.
This is...
When you're not sober, it's much more fun.
But...
When I'm sober and I have to deal with this shit.
It's actually miserable.
It's so...
It's so miserable.
Like...
It's not a good time.
Don't worry.
For real.
Like...
See guys?
They didn't say any slurs to me.
Because I was like...
I was like, sorry.
My bad.
I had a perfect excuse.
I was like, it was last fight.
I thought we could kill them all.
With double support.
With my damage.
And then I was like, also I thought you wouldn't get it in time.
No slur here.
I mean, we can see how close they are.
Alright guys.
Let's see how close they were to...
To top 500.
Let's see.
Alright.
Oh.
387.
Brother, you're not making it.
You have three...
Less than three hours left.
Oh man.
Okay, I...
I was like, oh man.
I'm sorry man.
No, I know this guy.
This guy is really good.
Everyone is...
Is dooming right now.
I don't know.
Unless he gets five wins in a...
He needs five to six...
Wins in a row.
To get it.
But he has to get six matches.
And he has to get six wins in a row.
The doom is real.
Yeah, it is.
It is real.
It is so real.
Everybody went through what I had to go through.
Oh man.
It's so...
Oh my god.
I'm sorry buddy.
I...
I like to see where they're at.
In their stage of life.
I like to see...
I like to see where they're at.
Like how...
How close were you guys?
Rank warning is a hard life.
All five stages of grief.
We don't look at our quick play.
That was quick play by the way.
If you see defeat, defeat, defeat, defeat.
That was quick play guys.
That wasn't...
That was not...
Now this was my rank time.
But it got okay.
It got...
This was the stage where I quit.
It was okay.
And then it got here.
That was when I...
This is when I admitted defeat.
And then I was like...
I still want to get back my points though.
I...
This is where I was like...
It's over.
Alright.
Raccoon time.
We'll play one game of raccoon.
Unless we get a raccoon one trick.
We'll do one game.
I won my...
I won my rank game guys.
I also got like...
RNG'd so hard.
I got such a huge RNG advantage.
With my team.
My team was actually...
Stacked too.
I had soju.
I need like...
I need 30 more minutes.
And then it's over.
And then I'm free.
I'm free.
30 more minutes of this...
Don't worry.
30 more minutes and then I'll be gone.
I'll be gone.
I think a lot of people gave up too.
That's why the matches are taking a long time.
A lot of people just gave up.
Just like me.
Alright, are they...
Oh, they're roleplayers.
Oh no, people are killing.
I only saw like 2 kills so I wasn't sure.
Oh no, they're not roleplaying.
Actual gameplay.
Actual players, let's go.
I'm scared.
There's so many people lurking.
He literally just got a game.
Okay.
Are they roleplaying?
Wait, let me in.
Am I banished?
No, wait.
That is sad.
That is so sad.
If he didn't ult, I win that 1v1.
If he didn't get the health pack and if he didn't ult, I actually win that 1v1.
Non-roleplayers are not allowed in this building.
I wanna roleplay, guys.
I'm a roleplayer.
No need to shield me.
I'm here to roleplay.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, what the fuck?
Bad.
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
Stupid.
I'm so stupid.
Okay, I need heals.
Hello.
Am I gonna get flamed if I play Raccoon?
Let's find out.
Alright, let's see.
Who do I get?
Will I get flamed?
That's a very good question.
I wanna play.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, I'll swap off and then...
Oh, we don't even have like...
How am I gonna...
Where's my Punisher?
I don't even have...
Nobody actually plays Magic these days.
It's fine.
Magic is so bad anyway.
Oh.
Alright.
Hello, Groot.
I'm banning Adam.
Alright.
Loki?
Not Adam?
Let's have a three-way gamble.
Who's gonna win?
The 220% or the 60%?
Let's go gambling!
Yay!
Oh.
Wait.
Bro.
That guy actually took Raccoon.
Wait, he doesn't... No, he didn't want me to play Raccoon!
He actually took...
They took Raccoon because he wouldn't want me to play Raccoon!
Guys.
He didn't want me to do it.
That's amazing.
Bro.
He didn't want me to play.
What am I supposed to do if I can't play Raccoon?
Dude.
Oh, wait.
No, he is a Rocket player.
No, he is!
He is a Rocket player!
I don't want to DPS.
This life is too comfortable.
I don't know.
I don't know if he has...
I don't know if he is.
I'm not...
Okay.
Oh, no.
Man.
I just wanted to play Rocket.
If we lose the first point, I'm playing Rocket.
Because it's over anyway.
It's over anyway.
You and me.
It's our life.
It's just you and me.
I pulled him.
You're welcome.
It's just you and me.
I don't know how I got that pull.
But I'll take it.
Yippee!
It's more fun when you don't take it seriously.
Just you and me.
Boom.
Get out.
Don't touch him.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
She already got...
That's crazy.
That's crazy that she already...
Ugh.
Okay.
You get out first.
I don't care enough.
Damage booster!
See?
Look at that!
You caught her first.
Fucking clutch.
Look at that.
That was a beautiful wheel.
I want to play Rocket, please.
He doesn't want to try anymore.
He's just like, don't make me try.
It's end of season.
Don't make me try.
It's time to try, buddy.
You get...
This is your life now.
I wanted to play Rocket too!
He just threw me off.
Bitch.
You're fine.
I'm saving my ult.
Bro...
Bro got a 3k and wants to play Raccoon.
Oh, you guys can't see it because I have Raccoon.
Raccoon.
Blacklisted.
I wanted...
I wanted to play Raccoon.
What do you mean?
I fucking saved this bitch's life.
She's not an actual bitch.
I'm just...
I'm sorry.
Sorry, I got a little too intense there.
The amount of times I've saved her life...
With my right click.
She's not an actual bitch, guys.
Sorry.
Most annoying voice ever, later, forever.
Thanks for the hate view.
I appreciate it.
It gives me plus one on the category.
Never apologize.
First one if you're a hate viewer.
I think if they start like...
I live.
Okay.
Okay, I was not paying attention if they had a Wolverine.
I should have looked, guys.
That was my bad.
I was actually fucking...
I can't.
I need to not fuck around.
Sorry.
Okay, I got it.
Wait, they're one support.
Oh no, they have too many DPS for me to go rocket though.
That sucks.
Because we need double defensive.
Because of the amount of...
Because of the amount of fucking...
I fucked up his...
There we go.
What?
Why?
Okay.
Oh, it's for the...
Wait, but he didn't kill anybody.
Wait.
Wait, guys.
We might...
We might be fucked here with this.
What is this?
This end of season shit is crazy.
Not gonna lie.
They don't have supports.
Wait, we can just kill them.
Wait, what?
We win?
We win the point?
That's crazy.
I was not paying attention.
Yeah, I know.
What was that fight?
I was...
I was like, we win that?
Really?
What the fuck is going on?
Oh my god.
I can stay up here.
It's chill.
I solo ulted for me.
And me only.
I literally...
I was just like...
Solo ulting myself.
That's right.
I get to live.
Let's go.
Me, myself and I.
Oh shit.
I'm a team player.
Don't ever say I'm not against.
I want my...
I want my Luna to get her ult.
There you go.
There you go, she'll live.
I knew she'd live.
What is this game?
I'm a hero.
We just need more damage.
No gap.
Wait, I went two in a row?
Get over here.
Let's go.
Guys, this is eternity.
This is eternity.
Holy fuck.
Look at...
At your teeth.
Bro.
This is actually...
Wow.
I love...
I love rank.
See, you just gotta give up.
Like me.
You just gotta give up.
Just like what I do.
I'm gonna use the bathroom, guys.
And then the winds come rolling in.
Back.
I'm back, guys.
I have 15 more minutes.
Okay.
15 more minutes.
I mean, I'm already up one.
Let's just...
I'm literally up two.
So if we lose this one, I'm up one game.
So that's good enough.
It starts.
If I play...
I mean, technically, I don't...
I'm the drunk one here.
But yet, somehow...
The Doom Queers are more of an ELO terrorist than I am.
That's actually crazy.
The...
The sober people are...
Are...
Are doing worse than what I do.
In rank.
That's insane.
Like...
It's so...
It's so weird.
You don't know.
That's true.
I don't know if they're sober or not.
They could just be...
They could be like me.
Just drunk queuing.
But like, I don't know.
It feels like a lot of people are trying to see if they can get top 500 in the last three hours.
So like, who knows?
The desperation.
Yeah.
Drunk queue over...
It's not good.
Yeah, 100%.
Do I play what?
Let's just end it on a quick play.
I'll play Raccoon and quick play.
I don't think life is gonna give me Raccoon.
What's it at anyway?
How many games have I played?
Oh, come on.
Alright.
How much do I have to win?
I need to win 10 games in a row.
So yeah.
That ain't happening.
Look at that.
Let's go.
I need to win 10 games in a row, guys.
That's...
That's not easy.
That's why I'm here.
Matthews, thank you for gifting a tier 1 sub to SnowGold and Kirby.
Thank you.
Thank you for the reset for 11 months.
Alright, here I go.
Yeah, 10 games in a row.
Less than 3 hours is the reset for me.
Alright.
From what I know, I'm practicing for Season 2.
Hello, that's me.
It's Raccoon time.
There's so many people know me in quick play.
That's crazy.
Hello, everybody.
Oh, I learned this tech from my friend.
Like, you climb this and then you can do that.
You climb this and press shift.
I don't know if this is an actual tech, but you can basically zoom up really fast against the wall by that.
And then...
Woo!
The super dash.
Season 2 is gonna be...
Season 2 is Raccoon meta.
He has his new ult.
His new ult is like insane.
Well, like, there's so many...
The thing is, there's a lot of really, really fucking terrible Raccoon players who one-trick Raccoon and don't know how to do like, Raccoon movement and shit.
Like, all they do is just like...
They just do this.
That's literally...
That's literally all they do.
Like, they don't move around.
They just, like...
They just, like, sit there.
And I'm trying to, like, know, like, how to do proper proper, like, movement around and stuff.
Because you're supposed to, like, to properly play Raccoon at a higher ELO is to just frequently move around.
So most... Yeah, like, literally a lot of one-tricks actually just do this.
They literally just do that.
But you're supposed to, like, move around and, like, so people don't know exactly where you are and stuff.
And, like, so you don't get, like, easily dived and everything.
You're supposed to be, like, frequently...
Yeah.
And they have, like, lineups and stuff, too.
So, like, people don't know exactly where you are since you're so fucking tiny and annoying.
And those are, like, the good Raccoon players.
But, like, the good Raccoon players are usually just people who...
Oh my god, sorry.
I was fucking around there.
Sorry, I was, like, actually fucking around.
I wasn't trying to do anything.
There you go.
Alright, let's push up.
There we go.
Okay.
I leave now.
I leave.
Let's go!
Goodbye.
Goodbye, I'm sorry.
You have to be, like, everywhere.
Wait, I know you're one.
There you go.
The snake.
Yeah, see?
This is how, like, actual... Why can't, like, my one-trick Raccoon players do that, though?
Like, I don't understand.
It's so easy to not be a bot.
It's actually so easy to not be a fucking bot at this game.
Hello.
I'm gonna hide up here for a little bit because they don't know I'm here.
They actually don't know.
Oh.
They're all still here.
It's fine.
It's fine, I'm gonna save you!
Take the orb!
Oh, he got healed.
Don't worry, sir, I got you.
Don't worry, sir.
Oh, he saw it, he saw it.
Guys, guys, protect it, protect it!
No!
My rez!
Okay, push up, guys.
Oh, that's sad.
I wasn't paying...
Sorry, I wasn't paying attention.
Alright, here we go.
No, I'm defensive.
Oh, good luck.
Good luck, guys.
No, no, no!
Oh, we see more... I don't know.
Rocket is such an easy hero.
I feel like everybody's gonna fight to play him.
I feel like.
I tried to... I didn't want him to hit us.
Like, I mean, I didn't...
The reason why I didn't despawn is that he spends so much time trying to kill it.
He's not... Oh, shit.
He's not, like, shooting us.
That's why I didn't do anything.
That's why I was like, get him!
Please!
Get him!
Wow, I'm so annoying!
Why can't my Raccoon one-tricks do that?
I'm so sad.
Oh,
I think this team fell apart.
My team has already fallen apart.
That's crazy.
Come on, shoot it.
I know y'all want to.
Shoot my thing.
Shoot it.
Oh, that was so good from him.
Why did you run away from my heals?
Are you stupid?
Oh, shit, no, I'm stupid.
Wait, where did he come from?
Oh, he comboed my fucking ass.
It's okay.
My team's got this.
Don't worry, guys.
You can win this fight.
With the power of teamwork and all that shit, I don't know.
Don't worry, guys.
He's gonna get the...
Don't worry.
He's gonna get my damage boost.
For that one guy.
He's gonna get it.
Come on, damage boost.
You have damage boost.
Oh my god, he had damage boost.
He had damage boost and he ran away.
Strange, you had damage boost.
Why are you scared?
Rocket nurse?
More like rocket buffs.
Sorry, my amplifier still doesn't have the fucking...
What was it?
20% plus more shield?
That shit's fucking crazy.
Why was he so scared?
He was running away from one guy.
That's crazy.
I can't believe he was running away from one guy.
I was literally right clicking to heal him.
And he was still running away.
Yeah.
He ran away.
With an amplifier.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Oh yeah, you always want to see a cool key.
If you go Punisher and go up to this window, you can see the people.
Who's in it.
I can't do it in time.
I couldn't do it.
It's only Punisher and you just go against the wall.
And you can see what characters are playing.
Are you good enough for this?
Are you?
I don't know.
Are you though?
What if I just put it right there?
I just put the...
I literally just put the...
There's no way he sees it, right?
Bro, they didn't see it.
I told you.
He doesn't need this.
He has a free reset too.
I wish people would break this more often.
Oh my god, wait.
Why do my raccoons not break these?
This damage is so...
Oh wait, I should...
Hello.
Oh sorry, it's too far.
I threw the wrong area.
Sorry, buddy.
I was not paying attention.
Whoops.
That's fine.
It'll be fine now.
Now you guys can kill them all.
Come on, kill them all.
Give me this point.
It's just that easy.
Are you still alive?
Jesus Christ.
This damage is crazy actually.
Whoops.
Does he respawn?
Yeah, he does.
Okay.
He has to run all the way back though.
Because I literally put that in our spawn.
Don't worry, Bucky!
Whoops.
Bucky, where are you going?
Like...
No!
Wait, I can fly.
I am a hero.
What the fuck is wrong with all of you?
What the fuck?
I'm just a record!
I don't live.
My team died.
Out of everybody, my team dies.
That's crazy.
I lived.
Out of everybody, I'm the one that lives.
That's actually crazy.
See, I don't understand!
If you one-trick this character...
Why can't you do that?
I don't understand.
Shoot your gun.
Do your little thing.
You get extra damage.
Just kill this guy.
I don't care.
I just want you to kill him.
Just kill him.
With my extra damage.
Wait, that guy is one.
Luna is one, actually.
Where is she?
There we go.
Does he hit anybody?
Oh shit!
Whoa!
Where is my...
Oh, she's over there.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Use it for this.
That's right.
Here we go.
I could...
Oh, I should heal.
I should heal.
I could heal.
But I could also do that.
Yippee!
I expert rodent movement.
That's how you play an actual raccoon.
And then I spectated that one fucker.
That one trickster.
And I see her do this.
80 miles away from the team.
No, sorry.
The team would be...
Okay, Penny is the team.
This is Eternity Lobby.
And the people that one trick rocket.
No, I'd be far away.
I'd be all the way in that city.
I'll be in that city.
And I'll be doing this.
No, you don't understand.
That shit tilted me so much.
That actually...
You guys saw what I have to do as Luna and Invis during those two games.
Even when like not sober.
Even when I was not sober.
And that's the amount of shit I had to do.
And then I see...
And then I see that.
It actually like...
Oh my god.
It actually killed me.
I'm... what?
What happened?
Where's my...
Where did my Bucky go?
Guys, I have one hour to win 10 games.
Do you think I can do it?
I just have one hour to win.
To win.
To win 10 games.
Guys, do you think it's possible?
I don't think we're winning this one.
I mean, I could go like a real character.
But that's not fun.
I don't think it's saveable.
I don't think so.
Okay, this is what I saw.
Like, why would...
It's like the idea that the thing will eventually...
Oh, we're fucking dead.
I have no defense up yet.
This is like the only way to kill me.
Like an actual aimbot.
They need like an aimbot to kill me.
Turkey please, it hurts so much.
Guys, I don't think if I play an actual support or a DPS for this team that anything would change, guys.
I legitimately don't do nothing that I...
This team...
This team is might be a little special.
Okay, it's fine.
Maybe if I had another defensive ult.
Maybe?
Hello, I shall be here now.
You're so dumb.
You're so dumb, Max.
Alright.
Yeah, this team I don't know if it's salvageable, guys.
I don't know, guys.
Who is he gonna eat?
We're all split up.
Who did he eat?
Nobody?
Oh shit, oh shit.
Oh shit, no!
The only way to kill me!
I didn't know where he was.
Oh my god.
We were all there.
I was so confused.
I was like, where is everybody?
Alright.
It was just quick play, guys.
This is not an actual ranked match, by the way.
For those who are like For those who are like, oh man.
It's okay, it was quick play.
I'm fine with that.
I'm glad I did rodent.
I did fucking rodent in quick play.
We can tell it was- Yeah, don't worry!
We can tell it was quick play.
Yeah, congrats!
I made it!
I did it, everybody!
Yippee!
I fucking did it!
Guys, I actually did like quadruple the fucking damage of a regular rocket player.
See, it was quick play.
See, you can see the quick play.
Alright, guys.
I hope you guys have fun watching.
Good luck to all the remaining DoomQers.
Good luck to the remaining DoomQers that are still trying after an hour left.
Wait, actually...
What's the leaderboard right now?
Oh my god.
Yeah, good luck to everybody there.
Good luck to the remaining Doomers out there with an hour left.
Godspeed to you.
No, it's an hour left.
There's one hour.
Yeah, that's why it's crazy.
It's actually crazy.
How many...
A lot of people couldn't make it.
A lot of pro players couldn't even get in.
I know so many pros that actually couldn't even get in because it was just too doomed.
DoomQ was just too doomed.
But it's okay.
I think this changes for next season.
Is the game harder now?
No, it's because they didn't rank reset.
They didn't rank reset and because they didn't rank reset there's a lot of players that are super inflated because all they do is play the game every day and if you play the game every day you can hit a lucky streak.
This season was the first time I was like, who are these people?
I've never had a season like the last previous seasons I was like oh I recognize these players but like this season was the first time when I was queuing rank the last three days where every game was a person I've never seen before.
Like ever.
Like it was like the first time I've ever seen these people in my lobbies and it's like almost every game there's like three people I've never seen before and it's like it's very interesting.
Yeah so like it's because like there's no rank reset so like there's so many inflated players in like the higher elo that like it's like basically a gamble.
Cause like the first season, season one was more fun than season 1.5 season 1.5 was a fucking chore.
Like it felt like a chore when I was grinding rank.
When I was trying to like actively trying to climb but like when I was just playing for fun obviously when I'm playing for fun on stream, it's just me messing around so it didn't feel like a chore.
But when I had a purpose to try to end top 500 this season it actually felt like a chore, like a job
So like I hope that yeah there's like people, look at how many games these people have played.
I have 300 games played.
These are like 499 so like 494 matches and everything.
So cause that's includes, that's just um include, yeah that's right a lot.
Competitive 462 matches played.
Oh my god this guy's win rate is insane right?
No actually no it's 50-50.
And then you can get 50-50% so like look.
Oh wait no this guy, actually no this guy, oh my god this guy this guy has a 50, oh wait 50% win rate on Luna but uh wait no yeah you can actually get like a 50% win rate on your heroes and still be top 500 that's the thing with uh that's the thing with this season it's just so fucking inflated like there's so many that's like uh let's see like you see a lot of people with like so many wins but those are wins uh yeah 50-50 on your You're on your main character and still... yeah,
that's like... it's weird.
I told you, this season is weird.
It's so weird.
Um, so like...
It's very luck dependent on who you get.
You might get teammates that you actually recognize in the rank ladder or you get people who like you've never seen before.
Like I've had so many... I was like, who are these people?
I've never...
I've never seen them.
But the new changes for next season seem... I like the new changes for next season because it's solo duos.
So you can't stack anymore because in the higher elo it is very frustrating because everybody stacks.
Now everybody stacks because it's the only way to like make it so like the odds were in your favor.
So like you can't do more than duos anymore in Eternity+, which is really nice because like I hated that.
I hated that because it forces people to just um, it just forces people to like adjust like, you know, make sure luck was like make sure you it's not as luck reliant as possible.
Yeah, so I'm looking forward to that, but I'm also like not gonna try for top 500 next season.
I'm gonna play for fun because I definitely had a lot more fun.
I...
I had a lot of fun.
But yeah, thank you all for watching.
I finished my quota.
Yippee!
I gotta send the stream over to the stat marvel rival staff so I can be like I did the 2.5 hours that I needed to do.
Thank you everybody for watching everyone.
I hope you guys had a great time.
Um, for those who are new, my name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on YouTube.
So please check me out there.
You can do exclamation point YouTube to uh, to subscribe to me.
And if you want to know whenever I stream on Twitch I usually do the gorillaz streams on Twitch.
Uh, please check out my Twitter exclamation point Twitter.
Uh, and and follow me there.
And if you want to support me via other means, um, you buy my merch!
Uh, exclamation point merch.
Not plush because plushies are gone.
But yeah, um, other than that there's nothing else I have to show for it.
Thank you everybody for watching.
As always everyone, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
Any of you, stay up for me.
Head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!